le président de l'assemblée nationale
n'avait pas prévu annoncé ce vendredi
qu'il quitterait la politique à la fin
de son mandat une annonce précipitée
parce que le retour de bernard
drainville en politique avec la cac
vient de se confirmer puisque ça veut
dire françois legault évite les
questions sur son futur candidat vedette
moi ce que je souhaite le sait
qu'aujourd'hui on parle de françois
paradis puis pour ce qui est des
prochains candidats ben on en parle en
ces lieux
les partis d'opposition eux s'empresse
de critiquer bernard drainville j'ai
hâte de voir la la la la la grosseur de
la tasse de kool aid qu'il vaut boire
pour vendre l'aspect écologique du
troisième ligne de françois legault
parce que nos valeurs on y croit québec
solidaire pense qu'en recrutant le père
de la charte des valeurs du gouvernement
de pauline marois françois legault se
dirige plus que jamais vers une campagne
électorale qui porterait sur l'identité
il veut que les questions de l'urne ce
soit la laïcité et l'immigration donc le
recrutement du père la charte des
valeurs c'est tout à fait cohérent avec
cette stratégie là le parti québécois
accuse bernard drainville d'opportunisme
et doutent de son intégrité je suis
convaincu que le public va se poser des
questions sur cette conversion tardive
street à londres --ville pascal ac axes
la cac et dépendent avant un sondage le
parti libéral de son côté y voit la
preuve que françois legault veut ramener
le québec vers le chemin de
l'indépendance je pensais sont pierre
karl péladeau bernard drainville bernard
drainville grande pompe politique là
pour pour être un chantre du canada
bernard drainville va chanter la chanson
que françois legault a déjà entamé et
entonné sur la gouvernance séparatiste
mais les khakis te rappelle que leur
parti n'est pas souverainiste messieurs
drainville c'est un politicien
d'envergure voyez-vous monde et un
caucus très unie et tout le monde est
bienvenu mardi bernard drainville
annoncera sa candidature pour la cac
dans les vies il devra aussi justifier
son changement d'allégeance politique
d'un parti souverainiste à un parti qui
se dit nationaliste à l'intérieur du
canada ici pascal points-là ne radio
canada à québec